[Music]
I'm Edward I'm the head teacher
mathematics at Tobruk Technology High
School where a school almost 2,000
students with an incredibly broad
cross-section of students we're 58%
language background other than English
and we have a whole range of students in
terms of their achievement level in
mathematics from people who are the
highest academic performers to students
who struggle at every step of the way in
order to grapple with mathematics and
become confident and competent in it i
integrate collaborative problem-solving
into every lesson that I teach because I
view it as really central to the way
that people learn mathematics and the
way that they do mathematics out in the
real world some of the things that are
important to having that as part of my
classroom is making sure that students
have time and opportunities to interact
with each other
to give them the kinds of problems that
actually reward to them to talk to
another student who actually try and
wrap their head around another
perspective on a problem or another
solution to a problem that's equally
valid but just not the one that they
thought of to begin with and also making
sure that I pose problems that are
challenging enough but also accessible
enough for all students to be able to
have some success with experience you
know the ability to start on the problem
but also for the problem to have natural
extensions that can take even the most
competent mathematicians off into new
territory
when I think about collaborative
problem-solving in the classroom one of
the things that's really important is to
recognize that it is an intimidating
kind of experience for a lot of students
who maybe aren't as confident and
they're afraid to put their foot forward
or put their hand up or shout something
out that all their peers are going to
hear and maybe judge so one of the most
critical roles for the teacher is to be
able to take all of those interactions
and to speak and question in such a way
as to show students mistakes and ideas
and risk-taking are all welcome in the
classroom and so much terms on the way
you look at a child the way your tone of
voice is moving your posture and how you
textin and skin put and whether it's
exactly the answer you are searching for
or not you help students understand yes
your contribution to this classroom to
this lesson to your peers your
contributions of value so I think that's
a really important piece to make sure
that every student across the spectrum
is engaged all the working
mathematically skills that are
integrated into the syllabus
understanding fluency communicating
reasoning and problem-solving really
have to import into every single lesson
it takes a lot of time to develop as a
teacher to number one understand what
does it look like to actually do more
than just develop students ability to
repeat a procedure on a different set of
numbers that takes a lot of time and
that's really tricky working out how do
you question students how do you divide
up your time within the lesson to
actually cultivate those skills it took
me years and many missteps and working
out okay well this didn't work out well
how am I going to try and teach this
same concept again be able to bring in
these skills and make sure that students
understand okay this is more than just
repeating the steps of an algorithm this
is a whole different way of thinking I
think one of the reasons why it's so
important to devote that time and to be
willing to make mistakes as a teacher to
get that point is because our students
are really going to have a completely
deficient view of what mathematics is
it's all if all they're getting across
is okay I can answer questions I can get
a right number at the end and therefore
that's what makes me a good
mathematician and that's such a narrow
of what true mathematics ears so I think
that even though it takes so much time I
really think that if we don't invest
that time then really our students are
not getting across the real sense of
what mathematics is how valuable it is
to them and that's why I love seeing my
students talking to each other because
then I see right you're doing more than
just developing your own foundations I
can see you communicating that skill to
someone else I can see you communicating
the way you approach that idea to
someone else and I can see that person
who's listening gaining a new
perspective on a problem which they
didn't have before all of those kinds of
skills really are best developed when
students can work together on
problem-solving developing these skills
as teachers as a team of teachers as a
faculty that values using skills and
want our students to develop them takes
a lot of time and a lot of effort but
there are a lot of strategies that can
be put in place that help us as teachers
to develop this over time I think of
things like being willing to be observed
by peers and by our supervisors so that
we can gain a different perspective on
the way that we teach in the classroom
there are so many things that we do that
are helpful or unhelpful track kids that
we're not even conscious of because
we've been doing these for years there
are some strengths that we need to
emphasize and which an outside observer
can help us notice and say that's really
great keep on going with that and there
are other things which we realize oh I
didn't think that this was having this
effect on that gym or I didn't realize
that this came across it was unclear
that having someone else in the room can
really be helpful similar to that team
teaching as much as physically possible
it's such a wonderful resource
especially when you're trying to again
make sure that you differentiate across
your whole range of students and you
want to make sure students are getting
not just your way of approached but
someone else's and that'll extend them
or enable them to encounter ideas that
and work with mathematical problems that
they weren't able to solve for I think
lastly I would say that thinking really
carefully about assessment and
constantly asking that question of what
are we assessing why do we put marks on
this why is this something that we want
to include in a task that
giving to students when we keep on
asking that question we're doing more
than asking can you factorize can you
long divide we're looking for do you
have 30 here is that sense of reasoning
understood can you justify this argument
if we incorporate that and make that the
conversation that we're always having a
round of sester then so many things
follow from that and it helps gain our
perspective on the importance of
distance